the apex legends community is pissed
after months of bubbling anger
fans have been using the hashtag save
apex ranked
to slam everything that respawn has
failed to do
to address the rampant cheating and
ddosing in the game
nrg's sweet dreams led the voices with a
scathing twit longer
while respawn put out a statement with
what it intends to do
to stop the war on cheating before the
game is overwhelmed
[Music]
here we go with another cheating video
if you're watching this
you probably like these kinds of
cheating or scandal or hacking type
videos we do do a lot of these on this
channel
so make sure you're subscribed to the
score esports if you never want to miss
any of these in the future it's a good
idea
so there's no way to sugarcoat this apex
legends
definitely has a cheating problem fans
have been complaining about cheetahs
ruining their rank matches for a
long time now on top of that there's
also been countless reports of
hackers using targeted ddos attacks to
crash their games and make life hell for
everyone involved
it's a problem that has plagued everyone
from the lower ranked apex player to
those higher up the ladder such as
popular streamer mandy
well i think of yesterday i was three
hours and 20 minutes since my stream and
i only played one game
dude is so bad is the reaction or what
no i was dude i dude it was soap every
time i queued up and i got a game i just
got
ddoster hector and if you're not a
massive
battle royale fan let me tell you that
cheetahs
are a special kind of hell for those
that dedicate their lives to apex
apex legends isn't counter-strike pubs
aren't just for messing around on stream
while you wait for your next pro
games you need your rank matches to get
enough reps in in order to compete
and that all breaks down when cheating
is this bad
there's nowhere else to go there's no
face it or esea
in this world the cheating problem is so
significant that certain people
like tuffy for example have become minor
celebrities within the scene
he's been known to hold lobbies hostage
kill players if they don't do what he
wants and allegedly ddos official
tournaments because he can
tuffy and the game's cheating problem is
actually something we covered on this
show
just a month ago so it's not like
respawn are doing nothing about it in
fact
they're doing the exact opposite they're
doing everything they can
but the reality is it's one company
fighting the entire [ __ ] internet so
you know it's not an easily winnable
battle
now this ddosing issue is something that
respawn has been aware of for some time
now
earlier this month apex's lead security
developer
connor ford better known as hideout
stated that they were hard at work on a
fix
the respawn team is pursuing several
options to crack down on cheating in
apex hiring more people to focus on
manual bans
developing more tools to automatically
detect and
stop ddos attacks investigating ways to
more quickly catch and remove
cheaters from games now perhaps respawn
thought this might quell the community
but it didn't last long less than an
hour later nrg
sweet dreams put out a twit longer
titled empty promises and
false hope hashtag save apex ranked
in the post sweet dream states that the
community is now going through
its eighth or ninth consecutive month
of cheating and ddosing being quote the
principal
issue facing the rank ladder and its
integrity
sweet dreams then lays out a bit of a
backstory he talked about how the
servers located in japan
taiwan and singapore used to be overrun
with cheetahs that went largely
undetected
because there weren't many big twitch
streamers there to bring attention to
the problem
now according to him legitimate players
started moving to the n a
servers to escape the problem but the
cheaters weren't far behind
they were drawn to na because of fast
lobby times and the ability
to dodge hideout's sleep schedule and as
the head of respawn's apex security
hideouts is largely responsible for the
team that is trying to crack down on
cheating
last week he hit back at critics who
said he was lazy
adding that devs are human beings not
machines and
words affect them but as hard as
hideouts tried he couldn't be on top of
cheetahs 24
7 and sweet dreams said that this left a
window for cheetahs to run rampant while
he was
asleep he was clear though hideouts
wasn't to blame for this
quote this is not hideout's fault and
anyone who blames the man who has spent
hundreds of hours in effort to make the
game playable across
every region of the world for the last
few seasons
is delusional and should be treated as
such
this issue stems from apex legends
general lack of enthusiasm when it comes
to hiring or acquiring more people
who can serve to ban cheaters either in
real time
preferred or after the fact still decent
this appeal to hire more dedicated staff
is something that respawn did address in
their tweet
but the feeling from sweet dreams
twitlonger was that this was too little
too late
he went on to say quote myself and
almost every n a
eu streamer or public competitive figure
have come together because we
literally can't see the game spiral
further out of control
ranked as the backbone of apex and we
can't take it much longer
we have been offered empty promises of
focus on the issue
which from a result standpoint have been
complete
lies now for those outside of the scene
it might seem like apex has
two separate cheating and ddos problems
but according to sweet dreams more often
than not it's the exact same players
doing both
according to him if a cheater does
somehow get killed by a legit player
they will then maliciously ddos the
entire server
so that nobody can play that game now a
lot of these cheaters can be found in
high ranking lobbies since apex legends
is a free-to-play game
after they've been banned it's
incredibly easy for cheaters to make a
new account and boost their way back to
diamond and because the pool of players
gets smaller as you move up the ranked
ladder when you queue up for another
game
the same cheater will be in the next
lobby ready to do the exact
same thing again it's essentially a
gamble sweet dream says that every day
he and other streamers simply cross
their fingers and
hope that they get a couple of games in
that aren't ruined by cheaters
and of course if the streamers are
pulling their hair out over this
it doesn't really make for very fun
viewing quote myself and others have
asked thousands of people
in daily streams how they feel about it
from a viewer perspective
almost everyone has said that they often
find themselves not even tuning in to
apex streams anymore knowing how
miserable they will find the streamer so
these two pillars of the scene
ranked and streaming are under threat
and it's here where
sweet dreams ask the question what can
be done about it
well one idea he put forward was the
ability for
quote high profile reputable streamers
to have the ability to suspend cheaters
and ddoses on site
this is a solution that mandy has spoken
about on stream as well
give pro players a [ __ ]
ben button soon dude
your game is gonna die but of course
this raises the question
who pleases the police if the power to
ban people is given to certain players
however reputable they are who's going
to make sure there isn't an abuse of
power there
all it would take is one rogue streamer
or pro player to use the ban hammer on a
legitimate opponent for the whole trust
in the system to fall apart
it seems like something that respawn
wants to avoid given that they've only
talked about hiring
official employees to deal with this
matter and not enlisting community
members but even hiring people to help
hide out
manually ban people has received
criticism as a band-aid solution
there have been calls for a system that
can detect and
ban cheaters automatically at the moment
apex runs off a pretty
bare bone system called easy anti-cheat
the same one the fortnite uses
it's not nearly as sophisticated as
riot's proprietary anti-cheat
vanguard that's used in valorant and if
you want to know more about vanguard
there's actually a whole episode
on this show breaking it down for now
though having real humans assigned to
this might be the quickest way to stop
the flood
before it's too late okay so what you're
saying is
this will be a band-aid but like in my
opinion i feel like this would be kind
of an expensive band-aid
until they get the correct software
installed to handle it
automatically like instead of doing it
manually
yes i i think they needed something like
that they can set up
very soon that is a band-aid solution
for
the ridiculous amount of cheaters that
are rage hacking in ranked right now
sweet dreams ended his twit longer on an
exasperated note
saying quote all in all something needs
to be done
we are so done with it it's to the point
where we literally do not know what to
do we just sit around month after month
and nothing changes and it's
demoralizing
please take initiative and hashtag save
apex ranked
before it's too late the community heard
that loud and clear
before long save apex ranked was
trending on twitter
as thousands of players fired off their
own frustrations with the current state
of the game
even pro players from rival teams banded
together to show their support
imperial hal and rogue pushed their
followers to tweet the hashtag while
vaxlan declared
it might be time to fight fire with fire
despite the obvious frustrations
everyone who spoke out about the game
seemed to do it from a place of love
it's not hate for apex it's a desire to
see it reach its maximum potential
one freed from the cheetahs and ddoses
that have plagued it for most of the
past year
respawn has said they'll keep the
community updated with the changes
they're making
and their plans for the future for the
apex community
that couldn't come any sooner the apex
legends community
is pissed after
after months of bubbling anger fans are
using
the hashtag save come on stop hitting
[ __ ] pop filter
just stop hitting the pop filter